bene a tutti i ragazzi benvenute questo
luigi io sono famigliari ci siamo
conserve fair e siamo sul gioco
incredibile che vi faccio vedere in
questo momento che ha un nome storico si
chiama avocado fede che mi sono
dimenticato di mettere la webcam
perfetto pc così l'avvocato che è un
gioco splendido che ho già giocato una
volta nostra mente è una sorta di gang
bis unito a steve white ci sono le armi
ci si picchia
giochiamo perchè risulta come
introduzione è piaciuto a sparisce per
sé ha un potere perfetto ci siamo
funziona allora io sono l'arancione chi
è step di voi col martello immagini
quella verde non saperlo noi ci dobbiamo
picchiare mandare fuori dall'arena
e quello che rimane vincere questo qual
è la verità ci si può picchiare quindi
stordire è più stordisce una persona più
tempo rimane per terra e l'ha poi
schermo sarà né dato un colpo di culo
cose che non sai che non ne ho la minima
idea e saltate ne presentava lanciata
l'amiata un caffè il caffè che è male lo
scudo ma è una conchiglia no comunque
bevuto il caffè bellissimo per ora che
occhi ciò il caffè bell'azione che
tattica ma edizione il martello prendo
fair e prendo fare la butta giù smettila
mio dio mi ha salvato un per e credo non
ci credo non ci credo non ci frega ti
prendi il caffè ma edizione l'occhio
gara perche non fanno un lastra puglia è
stordisce se lo becchi vieni qua venica
io sono veloce commette col pugno e o il
caffè meriti a colpirla ma mai a 15 43
mangiamo hammami a sei stato bravissimo
come hai fatto a fare questa cosa è ciò
che passa alle mani ayew le macchine o
ciò che le macchine passano esattamente
dove siete voi in questo io credo che
una striscia pedonale attivi l'altra
macchia
ma le hai o sono vivo non dimora la
fermi che non detto io posso essere più
stupido sono stato un crollo sulle
scatole allora per non puoi fare nulla
per è così morta sparagli sparare
bellissima carro armato che sono
incontrati oggi e combatte non è vero
non lo è oggi vi farò vedere come un
pesce
mi sono incastrate come un pesce può
vantare un lanciarazzi
siete pronti bravissimo fenomeno a
questa difficile ma io voglio
avvalorando sono tutte voleranno arrivo
non ti attacca mai via perché no esperto
con starò qui si sono spostati dai raga
come rocket league
stessa cosa ciao come soprattutto come
sono di orte vieni bravi
vorrei che quei tasti direzionali poi
aumentare
[Musica]
e vabbè io ci credo aiuta ma io non ci
credo ma la mia se non ce l'ho fatto per
inserire la tua ora questa è l'arma del
potere va bene o mio dio voi cos'è
successo a dio bono bellissimo questa
l'arma bellissima e poi ho una tattica
non faccio mai nulla se non stare fermo
e sparare io voi da già pensato che non
era voglio un apolide esatto lo
schiaccio ci siamo stati tutti sono
gravi che l'hub rosa è fa che pazzo non
mi picchia referendum i bicchieri
chiarezza per terra almeno uscite da lì
ho vinto io
insomma che avuto per ultimo è bello qui
sono nello spazio non premette quei
tasti per andata bene non è vero nemico
di tutti noi non solo ci da tirare mamma
mia il martello l'hack che dolore ti
prego non lo vuole mi tengo aspetta che
venga non e non usare ma ciò che botta
con le mani con queste mani forti che
sono già pronto soggetto da fare
ricordate che in questa mappa si può
fuggire
andiamo bene sta scappando da sola sul
tridente voglia prendere è impossibile a
secret exit fi era per me il piano di
sorta
io non ho mai capito livello devi
saltare tra mongolfiere all'altro
semplicemente
occhio perché credono usa restino le
cimici prenderai mica me non prenderei
mica me esatto si no
rilassati mamma mia cosa ho visto cha no
yu gi oh mamma mia ragazzi
beh non lo escludo ma perché di
esplodere
sì se spari per troppo tempo sapere che
penso io
chi è il vostro puntano giubbotto olio
scusa mi sento come ninja aia di chi ha
lo picchia l'america fino fermo brava
per vedere altre armi ebbene grazie
volevo si protegge vieni qua non mi
spingerà a roncà di oggi la norma noi
stiamo buttando giù con l'incubo
dell'arma
[Musica]
bella ma fu lanciata c'è solo questo un
f16 fine allora che cosa ti amo non lo
fai ti prego divertire stordito per
volare lo faccio di federica vacca porca
ma sto puglia in ordine
e molla di mala
che male c'è ricotta mamma mia come ho
vinto non è possibile
insomma perché sono fatto io mamma mia
cosa stava succedendo dove sono finito
questo è lo sciacquone rack e difficile
da mandare non lo fare sei pazzo non è
vero sono caduto non spetta non so tutto
è successo è successo un casino
l'arrivo a posto la lascialo trovare la
macchina infernale questa paura che tu
ormai sei confinato lì ti prego non
l'hai mia non ci credo insieme si è
fissata la macchina dalla moto la
liberta e l'ho persa non usare sono vivo
incredibile no no è immortale del sud
avremo dal definita do nascimento ai 21
vola e l'altro gigante una boss fight
riserve nardis e vedere qualcosa
qualcosa senza la mamma mia
no non ci credo non ce la si cava bene
vado 16 tutti ma questa è la boxe fight
fantastica gigante contro il kraken cioè
ma come come hai fatto a uscire gran no
non ci credo
ragazzi questo va scherzavo è diventato
improvvisamente l'ultimo livello perché
e durato tanto ma era boss fight di
quelli credibili
ora che secondo ma poi diventa normale
muso sono godzilla re dei nostri no
mamma mia pur essendo grosso amico mio
non giocare con i tentacoli perché ci
finisci dello scià quale bellissimo
ragazzi iscritti schiacciate la
campanella prima di argenti sono i video
perché questo gioco merita
faremo altri episodi con the fair e io
vi lascio anche il vestizione loro
canale lasciato un bel hai capito che mi
è piaciuto e noi come sempre ci vediamo
alla pressione non mi parla di fare il
secondo episodio ragazzi giuro beh
ragazzi
[Musica]